hey this is kim from khan academy and
today we're learning about mcculloch
versus maryland a supreme court case
decided in 1819 that helped to define
the relationship between the federal
government and the states
the question at issue in this case was
whether the state of maryland could tax
the baltimore branch of the bank of the
united states
and whether congress even had the power
to create a bank of the united states in
the first place to learn more i sought
out the help of two experts
randy barnett is the carmack waterhouse
professor of legal theory at the
georgetown university law center and
director of the georgetown center for
the constitution neil siegel is the
david w eichel professor of law and
professor of political science at duke
law school so professor barnett could
you kind of set the stage for us what
was happening in this case what was the
overall context
well mcculloch versus maryland was a
culmination of a
30-year-old constitutional controversy
in fact it was the culmination of one of
the earliest controversies that we had
in the country and that is over whether
congress had the power to establish a
national bank a bank that would be a
corporation formed by congress and which
would have certain privileges that
congress granted it this was a proposal
that had been made by alexander hamilton
when he was secretary of the treasury in
the washington administration in the
very first year
of the washington administration and it
went to congress
and
there was a very very robust debate in
congress as to whether this measure was
within the powers of congress to enact
eventually congress voted that it was
and then before he signed the bill
president washington asked some of his
cabinet members to give him their
opinion on whether it was constitutional
and he heard from several of his cabinet
members uh he heard from his attorney
general edmund randolph he said it was
unconstitutional he heard from his
secretary of state uh thomas jefferson
jefferson said it was unconstitutional
and finally he heard from his uh
secretary of treasury who had proposed
it
alexander hamilton who said it was
constitutional and washington signed the
bill and it became law and it
established the the first national bank
of the united states this case arose in
may of
1818 when maryland sued mcculloch and he
was the cashier of the baltimore branch
of the bank and maryland sued him in
state court to recover a tax assessed by
maryland on the bank and this was a time
of intense hostility toward the national
bank
in a number of states the state banks
competed with the national bank
and there had been an economic panic in
1818
when the u.s bank called in its loans
and state banks that had loans from the
federal bank were crippled and in
response a number of states passed
nearly annihilative taxes on the federal
bank and that's the environment in which
in 1819 mcculloch against maryland came
before the supreme court
i find this very interesting because
this is something that we talk a lot
about in the early 19th century
the bank of the united states and
what was good about it and what was bad
about it and there are certain people
who were certainly enemies of the bank
like thomas jefferson and then later
andrew jackson
why did people object to the bank of the
united states so much
yeah there were a variety of objections
there was a real political policy
disagreement about
whether it was a good idea
hamilton had her had a nation-building
economy building
objective as the first secretary of the
treasury he wanted to pay off both the
national debt and the state debts from
the revolutionary war which remained
unpaid he was emphasizing manufacturing
and commerce and a national bank was a
key part of his plan
the bank
would make it easier for the national
government to raise taxes
to pay off debts
to make payments to obtain short-term
loans uh the notes issued by the bank
could function as a national currency it
could also provide a source of capital
for financing businesses
but the opponents had different ideas
one of the leading opponents in congress
was james madison who at the time was a
representative from orange county
virginia and what concerned
him and i think what's concerned many
people was that there was no expressed
enumerated power in the constitution
for congress to make a bank there was an
enumerated power to create a post office
but there was no enumerated power to
create a bank so the question is whether
the failure
or the silence of the constitution on
whether there was this power should be
construed in favor of having such a
power or not having such a power and
madison's concern
was that to imply such a power
especially when the way in which it was
being applied was very remotely
connected to one of the enumerated
powers that were in the constitution was
very dangerous because by that form of
reasoning congress could essentially do
whatever it wished and that would
violate
the basic pledge that this was going to
be a national government of limited and
enumerated powers so in congress what
was the power that proponents of the
bank used to justify passing it the
principal
power that they used was is called the
necessary improper clause necessary
proper clause says congress shall have
power to make all laws which shall be
necessary and proper for carrying into
execution it's foregoing powers those
powers on the list and all other powers
vested by the constitution and the
government of the united states or any
department or officer thereof this is
called the necessary and proper clause
it it allows for congress to make laws
incidental to the enumerated powers to
effectuate or carry in execution those
powers and supporters of the bill said
that the bank carried an execution a
number of powers it carried into
execution the taxing power carry into
execution the commerce power
uh the opponents of the bank said well
it may do that but it only does that in
a very attenuated way and therefore if
it can do this in order to effectuate
that power then it pretty much can do
anything to effectuate a power and
therefore it can pretty much do anything
and that's a big problem so
maryland sues mccullough and then what
happens
right marilyn sue's mcculloch because
maryland didn't pass an annihilative tax
it was a tax of
around two percent of the bank notes
issued by the national bank and maryland
won in the state trial court and uh
maryland won in the state supreme court
and this was really not a surprise at
the time
let's just say solicitous of the views
of the state
and
after the state supreme court decided
the case went to the u.s supreme court
on appeal so even though maryland sues
mcculloch by the time it gets to the
supreme court it's called mcculloch
against maryland because mcculloch the
cashier of the baltimore branch is now
the petitioner
he's requesting the u.s supreme court
review of the decision of the maryland
high court and mcculloch is asking the
supreme court to intervene and in
essence side with the federal government
over the state interesting so what are
the constitutional issues at stake
once the mcculloch case gets to the
supreme court
well the supreme court in a very lengthy
opinion has to consider a couple of
different matters first it has to
consider whether the states have the
power to tax a federal entity like a
bank
and that's where you have the famous
statement by john marshall that says the
powered attacks can be the power to
destroy
what he's talking about is the power of
states to tax a federal entity like a
bank might be the power of states to
destroy a federal entity and he he ruled
against that claim and he basically
argued that states couldn't have that
kind of power and a threshold question
before the supreme court decides that
question of state authority to tax the
national government is whether the
national bank can exist to begin with is
there federal power to create a national
bank part of what maryland is arguing is
that there's no federal power to create
the bank
and so in fact this taxation that it's
engaging in is unproblematic the first
question is whether the federal
government can create the bank and if
the answer is no the then the case is
over if the answer is yes then you get
to the second question of whether the
states can tax this part of the federal
government the national bank
so at this time the chief justice of the
supreme court is john marshall very well
known as being kind of the
the chief justice that brought the
supreme court to be a major player in
the
u.s governmental system
how did he interpret what was going on
what did he and the other justices
decide he borrowed extensively from
hamilton's arguments and so marshall
adopted hamilton's arguments in defense
of the constitutionality of the bank
that hamilton originally articulated
back in 1790
1791 and so the court
held an opinion by the great chief
justice first that congress does possess
the authority to create the bank and
secondly
that states have no authority to tax the
bank and that is what marshall concluded
was within congress's power under the
necessary and proper clause to enact and
in fact when it got to the court in
mcculloch versus maryland
it was the state of maryland who
basically adopted the jeffersonian
approach and said that a measure must be
in its words indispensably requisite or
what you might call absolutely necessary
in order for it to be constitutional and
whereas the defenders of the bill of the
bank bill said that it could be a lot
less than that so i think that there's
basically three positions that you can
have it has to be indispensably
requisite or
logically necessary that's the jefferson
and maryland view it could be merely a
matter of convenience or expediency
meaning
basically congress can do whatever it
wants that's the liberal view that
sometimes attributed to john marshall in
mcculloch versus maryland but he denied
it and there's the in-between position
that i think both madison and hamilton
were favoring and that is the
requirement of some degree of means ends
fit so that a measure really is aimed at
a particular end and it's not really
trying to accomplish something that
congress isn't given the power over what
i think is less well known about this
case
is that the case was that this part of
the case was over and the court had
already decided
that this federal power to create the
bank before it even got to the necessary
and proper clause
this case is a great example of what's
called
structural constitutional interpretation
hamilton articulated two structural
principles
first that the federal government is
supreme within its sphere of action
and second
if some kind of end
is within federal power is listed in the
constitution
then any convenient or useful means to
accomplishing that end is with also
within the scope
and so marshall decides that drawing
inferences from his understanding
of the theory and structure of
government created by the constitution
and only after he does that does he then
turn to the necessary and proper clause
to confirm what he has already
deduced through what he calls general
reasoning
so mccullough versus maryland is
frequently paired with marbury versus
madison as being
two cases that really decide the extent
of federal power in this early era do
you think these two cases are related
what do they tell us about the ideas at
this time period about federal power
well they're very important i don't
think they are quite as extreme as
they've come to be read after the new
deal when the new deal court and
advocates the progressive advocates for
a new deal
were going back into the past and
seeking justifications for what they
wanted to do they read mcculloch versus
maryland very broadly they also read
marbury versus madison actually they
read barbary versus madison in some
respects very narrowly because they
didn't want courts invalidating their
new deal legislations marbury versus
madison was not a huge deal at the time
it was decided the idea that judges had
a duty to follow the higher law when it
was in conflict with the mere statute
was widely accepted at the time of the
founding and so marbury was not
announcing a new policy
mcculloch versus maryland on the other
hand was extremely controversial when it
was decided and in fact quite
uh oddly
uh james madison who had signed the bill
authorizing the second bank into law
greatly strenuously objected to john
marshall's opinion in mcculloch versus
maryland upholding the bill that madison
had signed into law so
madison still maintained that marshall
uh had a uh latitudinarian or broad
overly broad interpretation of federal
power even in upholding the bill that
madison by this time had come to believe
was constitutional
so what ultimately happened with the
bank of the united states
what ultimately happened is both the
first bank the bill creating the first
bank and the second bank had what's
called a sunset provision which means
after a certain amount of time and it
was 20 years it expires and so to
reauthorize it it puts the burden of
inertia on those who want the thing to
continue and so congress had to pass
another bill reauthorizing the bank and
president andrew jackson
opposed reauthorization president andrew
jackson vetoed the reauthorization of
the bank and it was very interesting
because he vetoed it on constitutional
grounds he said it was unconstitutional
and yet
what happened to mark mcculloch versus
maryland if mcculloch versus maryland
said the bank was constitutional how
could president jackson
say that it was unconstitutional well it
was interesting because what mcculloch
said was
that the bank was constitutional as an
exercise of congress's power to make
laws that are necessary and proper that
congress believed was necessary and
proper and because congress believed it
was necessary and because the measure
was plainly adapted to a legitimate end
in the constitution then it was
constitutional what jackson said was hey
look
the court said that it's up to congress
to decide whether something is necessary
and therefore constitutional and i as
president
exercise the veto power as part of the
legislative process therefore it is up
to me to decide whether the measure is
necessary and therefore is
constitutional so i as president have
decided that a bank is not necessary
and therefore because the bank is not
necessary it is unconstitutional and
mcculloch versus maryland allows me
as a participant in the legislative
process to make that call
congress did not override jackson's veto
and the bank expired and the story ended
in 1836 and i think this speaks to one
of many morals of the story of the bank
of the united states the supreme court
doesn't have the last word on
constitutional questions when it upholds
exercises of federal power it's then
left to the political process to decide
whether or not it wants to continue
whatever controversial action or
legislation was at issue so is there any
aspect of mcculloch versus maryland that
still affects us today one reading of
mcculloch is that it gives congress a
broad
power so broad that allows congress to
exercise any power
that it deems convenient to the exercise
of one of its enumerated powers that's
that is how mcculloch has come to be
interpreted i think that is an
overreading of mcculloch
and it also
uh overlooks um one of the key passages
of mcculloch versus maryland that
nowadays is given no legal effect by the
supreme court this is what john marshall
said should congress under the pretext
of executing its powers past laws for
the accomplishment of objects not
entrusted to the government it would
become the painful duty of this tribunal
should a case requiring such a decision
come before it to say that such an act
was not the law of the land so what
marshall is saying there is
that um just because congress says
it a law is necessary to one of its
numerated powers doesn't make it so and
if there is a lack of fit between means
and ends suggesting that in fact
congress is trying to pursue one of the
powers that was not given to it under
the constitution
it really would be the painful duty of
the tribunal to say it was not the law
of the land and that connects this case
back up with marbury versus madison in
which it is the painful duty
of the supreme court to say that a
statute is not the law of the land if
it's unconstitutional that that aspect
of mcculloch versus maryland is no
longer followed in part because during
the new deal the supreme court said that
it would not inquire into the motives
of congress in enacting laws and in fact
what mcculloch is saying here is to
inquire into the motives it's to say hey
look it's really it purports to be doing
one thing but it's really
doing something else and that is
pretextual you know the there were there
has been irreconcilable disagreement on
basic constitutional questions from the
very beginning of the constitution
madison and hamilton who come together
and write the federalist papers they
disagree about this fundamental question
of strict versus loose construction of
congress's enumerated powers they also
disagree about congress's spending
powers they disagree about inherent
executive power so sometimes originalist
constitutional arguments
presupposed a greater degree of
consensus
about what the constitution means
at the start of the country that i don't
see when i study the history we have
always disagreed we've always managed to
find some kind of community in
disagreement it's the conflicts and
disagreements that have uh
binded us together
as much if not more than the agreements
we've had about what the constitution
means
so we've learned that mcculloch versus
maryland was about far more than just a
tax on a bank it bolstered the power of
the federal government by broadly
defining the necessary and proper clause
and by confirming that federal law is
supreme to state law to learn more about
mcculloch vs maryland visit the national
constitution center's interactive
constitution and khan academy's
resources on u.s government and politics